les épines qui formaient la grande voile dorsale.
On avait les os de la jambe, les os du crâne,
les pieds palmiformes, des pieds larges.
Là encore, très inhabituel ; aucun autre dinosaure
n'a des pieds comme ça --
on pense qu'ils servaient à marcher sur les sédiments meubles,
ou peut-être pour barboter dans l'eau.
Nous avons également examiné la microstructure fine de l'os,
la structure interne des os du Spinosaurus,
et il se trouve qu'ils sont très denses et compacts.
Là encore, on voit ça chez les animaux
qui passent beaucoup de temps dans l'eau,
c'est utile pour le contrôle de la flottabilité dans l'eau.
On a scanné tous nos os et construit un squelette de Spinosaurus numérique.
Quand nous avons regardé le squelette numérique,
nous nous sommes rendus compte que oui,
c'était un dinosaure sans pareil.
Il est plus grand qu'un T. rex,
et oui, il a une tête de mangeur de poisson,
mais en fait tout le squelette montre qu'il aimait l'eau.
Des os denses, des pieds en forme de pagaie,
et les membres postérieurs sont de taille réduite,
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qu'on voit chez les animaux
qui passent une quantité considérable de temps dans l'eau.
Donc, comme nous avons étoffé notre Spinosaurus -
je parle des attaches musculaires et d'envelopper notre dinosaure de peau -
on se rend compte qu'on a affaire à un monstre de rivière,
un dinosaure prédateur, plus grand que T. rex,
qui régnait sur cette ancienne rivière de géants,
se nourrissant des nombreux animaux aquatiques
que je vous ai montré plus tôt.
C'est ce qui en fait une découverte incroyable.
C'est un dinosaure comme nul autre.
Certaines personnes me disaient :
« C'est la découverte d'une vie.
Il ne reste pas beaucoup de choses à découvrir dans le monde. »
Je pense que rien ne peut être plus loin de la vérité.
Je pense que le Sahara est encore plein de trésors,
et quand on me dit qu'il ne reste pas de lieux à explorer,
je me plais à citer un célèbre chasseur de dinosaures,
Roy Chapman Andrews,
qui a dit : « Il y a toujours eu une aventure juste là au coin,
et le monde est encore plein de coins. »
C'était vrai il y a plusieurs décennies,
quand Roy Chapman Andrews a écrit ces lignes.
Et c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)